ambiance plage à la ville le stade de
france va transformer sa pelouse en base
nautique 9000 mètres carrés de sable
pour jouer au ballon et un grand bassin
pour se baigner ou s'amuser l'opération
dure une semaine
reportage julien beaumont et gilbert
usant ça ressemble à la plage ça a le
goût de la plage et pourtant nous ne
sommes pas à la plage mais à saint denis
sous les gradins du stade de france
le sable 2500 tonnes en tout un espace
de jeu unique pour découvrir de nombreux
sports comme le beach rugby pas parce
qu'on dit qu'à tous les grands joueurs
du rugby et se foutent sacrifier nous ne
la manquait dans ce bassin 50
millilitres d'eau une initiation à la
voile encadrés par des moniteurs
alors là c'est l'arrière de l'arrière du
bateau l'avancé par là
on s'amuse bien il ya un et planche à
voile et pointé les
certains d'entre eux n'ont jamais vu la
mer certains d'entre eux parlent et la
piscine mais non pas du tout l'habitude
de flotter sur l'eau et de se diriger et
pourquoi pas pour certains d'entre eux
effectivement avoir le goût le plaisir
une douzaine d'activités sont proposées
au public les enfants dès 4 ans peuvent
participer coup de la journée 10 euros
par personne
un financement cette année sur fonds
privés c'est un budget de 450 mille
euros qui est financée essentiellement
par le stade de france avec le soutien
le partenaire officiel
l'opération se termine le 29 juillet
l'occasion pour ceux qui ne sont pas
encore parties de réviser les
fondamentaux avant d'arriver sur la
plage la vraie